just now come from it spray minister me
about this proposal and the light will the
kan foundations
de toughness conduct this over the paste
hi believed the shot extension of the
possible but it really conditional
of fitting the error of the we stray
client in the house  of commons
the crèche and who my wife and esther de
quraysh and depose and extension
prime minister me is proposal of the
skipper john how I give something more the
create you physically of questions of legal
and politics to my scarf
members devil this card is tomorrow when
it comes today today's show
strassburg agreement
hi move the this is possible are in
my yoga are at create erase er
special lifted the target wood
the ratification process in the yokai at this
time
hi donald goofy and get real to
lilianne chances there is every
at pro easy  to be in dash and there
is a positive old and the house of
commons next week and finalize one
of the lowest decision on the extension
in the white cruci  aal we keep at
station he me that he the time and blowing
members of the raw bianca fan of a
meeting to brussels next week
i love it refine afs brass
frame
i am louis and then the use this
fatigue is increasingly the renovation and
justified
who can never hurt sikkink other the
very last moment and positive solution